y la extrema derecha ha estado apuntando
a hacer un borrón y cuenta nueva pero no
fue así el tradicional bastión de la
izquierda la toscana habría sido el
máximo premio pero un recuento parcial
de los votos yo al candidato del partido
democrático una cómoda ventaja sobre su
rival de la liga matteo salvini habló
sin embargo de progreso que cuando
hablaba con miniaturas llorando cuando
empezamos a pensar en las elecciones en
la toscana hace unos meses algunos de
sus colegas nos preguntaban por qué
estábamos entrando a competir cuando
estábamos 15 o 20 puntos por detrás de
la izquierda
perdimos eso está claro pero estoy
contento porque estoy seguro de que
muchos de ese 40% que nos votó solía
votar por la izquierda o revisionista la
liga se mantuvo en las regiones de
benneteau y lujuria y mientras que otro
partido de extrema derecha los hermanos
de italia parte de una coalición
liderada por la liga de salvini le
arrebató le marqué al partido del primer
ministro y giuseppe conte el centro
gobernante dejó la coalición mientras
tanto se mantuvo en cuatro regiones
incluyendo la toscana
nicola zingaretti el líder del partido
democrático
se sintió claramente aliviado no es amor
estamos muy muy satisfechos
esta es una confirmación de que el
partido democrático es una fuerza del
cambio en la fuerza del campamento los
expertos habían advertido que una
victoria para la extrema derecha habría
sido catastrófica para la frágil
coalición nacional de gobierno de
izquierda liderada por el primer
ministro y giuseppe conté estos
resultados son exactamente lo que la
izquierda había estado esperando